we're on season 2 of Riverdale and
season 1 was a massive success how did
it feel coming back for season 2 this
year um it felt like I was ready for it
and that I felt like I learned so much
season 1 just like about not just the
industry but also just acting-wise
skills wise so coming into season 2 I
felt like I had a lot under my belt
were you prepared for the massive
success that Riverdale was gonna be like
your life has changed since the season
once done yeah I try not to think about
it like I'm just you know it's changed
but you know it's not like where the
Selena Gomez's of the world you know so
I feel like famous fleeting I think
you're discrediting yourself because
fame isn't gonna be fleeting anytime
soon this show in season 2 is growing
bigger than it even did in season 1 and
I think your ain't gonna be in for a
ride no no I guess we'll see it what do
you what do you love about playing
Veronica what attracts you to the
character of Veronica um I love how
confident she is I think it's really fun
to step inside of her body um she just
carries herself a certain way she's
really funny she's really quick she uses
words I never use yeah she's just a fun
person to be I've always felt more like
a Veronica myself than Betty yeah I can
I mean she there's been a lot of heavy
subject matter with Veronica this season
it's been a little bit of a shift from
season one what can fans expect in
season 2 with the character um I think
Veronica's headed in a bit of a darker
direction because we didn't get to
really see dark Veronica last season I
think we kind of heard about her being
darker in her past and then season was
season one was about Veronica being
sweet and trying to reinvent herself and
season 2 I think as she's getting more
involved with her parents she's kind of
stepping back into the dark world and in
the world of corruption um so she's
trying to learn how to balance those two
things like good and evil and trying to
steer her parents into the direction of
good as much as she can
your parents are she so she's super
shady yeah
so with Sugarman being arrest
and killed do you think that's the end
of jingle jangle or do you think jingle
jangle will make an appearance in
further episodes down the road I'm not
entirely sure but I think I think jingle
jangle could come back are you hoping to
never say it like it's like the maple
syrup with season two I want to quickly
talk a little bit about Betty and
Veronica's relationship and season two I
feel like that's gonna be developed a
lot more of this season what do we have
coming for those two um I think we have
more conflicts which is nice I mean
obviously we love to see Betty and
Veronica as a duo together but also I
think it's interesting to see them maybe
at their weak points and because there's
so much going on in Riverdale you know
always the drama that affects their
friendship so seeing that play out I
think the audience will really enjoy it
they're both really strong female
characters which I love yeah which i
think is so great about the series their
own ways to they both have their own
strengths about them and I think what I
love and a lot of people love is the
situations and the you know we talk
about sexual assault about rape drugs
like these real things that people are
dealing do you think that's been
something that maybe fans have latched
on to you think you're saying yeah and
and it's funny because we talk about
these things and we're always a little
bit scared you know I think going into
it what are people gonna think about the
topics and like the reaction is always
positive so why would you tell people
they should continue to watch season 2
of Riverdale what's coming up in the
season that has you excited that will
have the fans excited I think there are
twists that we don't even see coming and
the audience especially won't see coming
and I think you know when things get
resolved you're not entirely sure if
they're resolved you know I think the
plot can be misleading